hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
i've gotten a lot of requests to do
more headphone testing and more uh
reviews of them
in video of denim and text on audio
science review
so i thought i'll go ahead and show you
a review but more importantly show you
my procedure and process for doing
reviews
how to interpret measurements and
understand concepts like equalization
and the specific headphone i thought i
do a
demonstration of is this uh high five
man he
six is a discontinued headphone but for
his time
was one of those premier headphones that
came out
on this thing so but before i can
get into uh telling you about headphone
measurements i need to explain
what my measurement system is um unlike
speaker testing where the concept of
uh frequency measurements and objective
analysis is still somewhat obscure and
unknown by many people
in headphone world the uh community uh
oddly enough has understood or learned
or heard
a lot more about speaker headphone
measurements and specifically work that
dr sean olive has done at harman to try
to quantify
what uh objective measurements lead to
good subjective
experience with a headphone um but the
research is is kind of tricky uh but uh
two years ago a year and a half ago when
i decided to either get into headphone
testing or
speaker testing i you know i knew about
the research in speaker testing and the
barrier
there was really just the cost of the
equipment and dealing with logistics of
testing large speakers
but with headphones the research is a
lot more complicated to understand
and it relates to how we measure them
for speakers i have a system that
generates anechoic response of a speaker
and it's extremely repeatable and
reliable system
not so with headphones so let's start
with uh
you know how headphone measurements are
performed
um you don't just stick a microphone at
a headphone right
where would you stick it uh you know
they had their different headphones
different sizes and shapes
um people have come with different
schemes you can take a cheap microphone
stick it in a flat plate and put the
headphone against it and you get one set
of measurements
or you can do it to professional
companies that make this kind of
measurement instruments bnk one of them
and grass is the other one
head acoustics is the third one and uh
by the various measurement gear um
there's a challenge in doing that though
the research that sean olive did
correlated measurements with the
specific fixtures that he
used if you go use a different uh
fixture they're really on your own in
deciding what that frequency response
means
and as i'll explain in a second it is
not a notion of having a flat response
flat response does not exist that
concept in headphone testing i'll show
you in a second
but this is the fixture that i have is
the grass
45 ca from the
uh danish company i think grasses with
denmark
uh they've not joined forces with audio
precision so
same company sister company to them um
but essentially this thing is also
called the hammer by the way it's i
can't show it to you because it weighs
30
40 pounds sitting next to me over here
uh it's a
very very heavy uh fixture it's not a
plastic or anything it's like feels like
there's tons of lead in there which is
great to stabilize the
fixture and not let it be subject to
vibrations and resonances from the
headphone
but the business end of it is this this
artificial ear or pinna it actually sits
on the outside the microphone the
measurement mic is actually deep inside
this
thing and the first generation of these
ears were actually
quite stiff and that caused the problem
for on ear headphones that set on your
ear
they wouldn't be able to flex them just
like you know the way your reg
real ears flex and as there's a lot of
bass with scape
harmon discovered this and built their
own artificial ear
out of silicone and grass then later on
went ahead and
built their version which is what i own
it's very supple
very soft it feels like your ear maybe a
little bit less cartilage in it than my
friendly hair has
but essentially it's uh soft and it
fluxes so if you put the headphone on
and it's not 100 running it still can
make a good fit
whereas if you have something rigid uh
like mini dsp had it has this ears one
has the stiff ears if you don't get the
cup all the way around it actually
cup stands proud from the stiffness of
the
artificial ear so what harmon did uh
prior to what harmon's work was that
people had two ways of calibrating these
the manufacturers of these things they
would stick this fixture
either in the nano quake chamber and
play one tune at it
one node added or frequency sweep and
see what it measures
or to put them in a highly reflective
room having reflections come from
everywhere and give you that
and people assume that so that would be
the neutral curve in a
in a headphone therefore you should
replicate that when you're measuring
headphones and anything deviating from
that is wrong
harman's research found that neither one
of those correlated well with
listener preference and that a better
method was to actually go in a reference
standardized listening room put in a
very highly rated speak and when i say i
rate it i mean it did extremely well in
listening test
and objectively also and then record
that
output and that frequency response um
with a dummy head that sort of it's a
hat it's called hats a
head and torso simulator and then
translate those
measurements to this exact fixture that
i'm using although they are using their
own
painter their own ear which is a little
bit different than this so some minor
inaccuracy exists
but otherwise this is the fixture that
they use
and using this then they studied and
figured out
what the correlation should be between
control listening tests
with headphones and then uh
frequent response measurements with this
now it's still a very tricky business in
that
you can't do proper control tests with
headphones
if i put this on my ear blind somebody
puts it on my head versus
this akg headphone they're going to feel
very different than i can
instantly cue you know figure out which
one you're putting on my head and say oh
that's that must be that headphones you
can't randomize this selections
so harman resorted to a um a simulation
of that and that they use the headphones
on the same headphone all the time for
testing
but they measured each headphone on a
fixture like this
and then eq that one target headphone to
be the sound of these things
that's kind of fuzzy uh science there
and you just have to allow some amount
of uncertainty there because
one instance that i've looked at what
they say they measured on a frequency
responsible headphone i can't even get
anything close to what they say they've
measured
and part of the problem is that when you
put these headphones on these fixtures
you can't always get the same seal
and therefore frequency response changes
and so one solution people will come up
quickly
which is we do five or six times and we
average them
there's no guarantee if averaging does
you any good uh what if i do
two or three really wrong settings on
this i actually don't want to average
those i want to throw all that out
and find the most optimal one and then
again when you wear it
what is the optimal way you wore it
versus what the fixture sees
so when it comes to frequency response
analysis and objective analysis of
headphones
you have to allow for a certain amount
of uncertainty
nothing about headphone analysis or even
equalization should be about precise
uh assessments you know when we look at
electronics they're
iron clad measurements there's zero
variable variability there's no
unknown so when i have my audio
precision measures i'm you know it's
measured that's it
speakers they move a little bit to the
left there's
9 80 to 90 representative because
there's still techniques and how you
measure it and what have you
with headphones i'd say we're down to 60
70 percent
sometimes the headphone cooperates and
in this case it hit actually with a g6
uh but some other times they do not
where i can put a headphone on and it
just shows such drastic differences
in every time i mount it that you just
have to learn and i'll show you how you
learn that technique of
of uh being aware of the fact that we're
not talking about
super accurate assessment in
measurements
of of uh headphones okay
so this is the fixture you put it on it
just has two microphone outputs
it goes through a specialized
preamplifier from grass
uh by the way nothing's cheap this is
fifteen thousand dollars so the
amplifier is a thousand dollars
and then i run them into my audio
precision analyzer so another twenty
eight thousand dollars
um you can put route this into a sound
card and capture things so
maybe instead of twenty thousand dollars
you have a few hundred dollars
but i like the way the simplicity of
using my audio precision analyzer so
the measurements you see are used in
that although there's nothing special in
this case
acoustic measurements have a lot of room
noise and as just explained a lot of
variations so we're not after
0.01 precision in anything um
you know this again correlated and
roughly accurate measurements
but they're they have issues in them
okay so
anyway and that unfortunately creates a
barrier
you know if you don't have this fifteen
thousand dollars you're in trouble now
berlin care has a 45
000 uh hat system that's similar to
upper body
they say it's designed to be more
accurate than this they were kind enough
to loan me one and i tested it for a
while
but i tell you i could not get anything
out of it that i could use
because there's no research to show what
is the correct frequency response for
that
so for a change spending more gets you
less with that
so be very careful when somebody shows
your frequency response measurements
and they don't tell you and it's not
this model
and there's no research to back it now
relatively speaking
if you have always tested all the
headphones using the same
gear sometimes for for many cases
especially if you have good eye you can
analyze and get useful results there are
some hobbyists that
do an excellent job there but in general
to do it right in my opinion there's
only this solution
going higher end causes problems for you
going lower and
gets you a lot of having to explain why
your fixture
matches what the research says so a lot
of talking but
so let me go into a review and and show
you
in practice what that means so i took
this uh
hifiman and uh it says different paths
turn out the bats to be actually it
old ones wore out but it's it's really
the stock ones
and i put that on and boy did this thing
fit like a glove on my measurement break
i've never seen anything
fit this well the cups are very big so
when you put it around it really
seals nicely and it's not pushing or
changing the
uh the artificial ear and not only did
it match
well as far as variation but each
channel matched perfectly and you can
see this i'm doing a stereo
sweep in here which is by the way an
advantage of my uh
grass measurement records that has two
microphones in it
then some other reason makes it
expensive but it enables me to get two
instances of measurements out of one
headphone rather than just measuring one
and then not knowing what the other one
does
there's a 43 ca version of it
that is just a cup in a cup where you
can only measure one side of the
headphone you have to clamp it somehow
and that in my opinion is not as good as
this because you only get one side of it
and
a new artificially mounting it doesn't
just mat mount just like a headphone
does
so anyway the harman research shows that
this
dashed line is more or less
what we want to see why is it looking
like this first ignore the left side
it peaks up like this because our ears
in ear canal this whole shape is
designed to amplify
these mid-tones the two to five
kilohertz are we're specially sensitive
to
and we have the best dynamic range and
lowest noise level
because our ears are basically
magnifying that for
evolutionary reasons with you know our
hearing and everything is optimized
around that frequency
and below that you lose that gain
and things flatten out uh and above that
we start to lose
just general hearing anyway um
now harman initially went with the
with a curve that was flat from here on
all the way down to
tony harvest but they realized that
people liked more bass out of headphones
and indeed when you're listening to
speakers you're feeling the bass also
physically and there's room games and
other things that
and and also a general preference for
base we'd like to hear a base
and uh so they experimented gave people
knobs to adjust more or less bass and
treble
and they updated their preference curve
to have this much bass in it
now if you read the forums and
everything immediately people came out
and say oh that makes
you know harmon response means is boomy
and basic
it is not most of the emphasis is all
the way down to
20 30 40 hertz and that's a reason
actually
most of you have not heard what's in
your music i test hundreds of speakers
hundreds of the dozens not speakers
that don't even play the content that
that's this low
and with headphones when you apply this
boost in here
you hear this sub-bass region that is
just incredibly pleasurable to hear
you hear deep deep notes that to have
speakers that go this low you need
incredible freestanding speakers that
can be
flat response basically to 20 hertz uh
maybe your subwoofer can get there and
then you've done all the
optimization but i'm telling you you
have not heard
proper sub bass until you hear it on a
headphone that's that's this that's slow
distortion
and he's able to go this deep so i'm
completely a believer
in this boost and i've and i've always
compensated for it if a headphone just
like this doesn't give you that
and i've never never found it to create
boominess
and i'll show you later on how i applied
but remember that this base region can
be highly variable because
depending on how much air leakage there
is around the headphone
this curve can actually tip all the way
down here in a measurement in reality
you may wear it you may get higher
amount of bass but measurements often
show 10 15 20 db
deficiency in there so
you got to look at this as an
approximate thing number one
and number two is a preference thing but
i'm telling you when i give you an
equals that he said
i'm picking something that i think will
suit just about
everybody rarely do i hear somebody
applying my equalization and come back
so whoa it goes all boomy
it is not designed to get boone
boominess will come from this 60 to 100
hairs if you boosted the heck out of
this region then you get boominess but
not in the deep bass so anyway this
headphone seemed like some great effort
was put in there to get it to have a
flat response in here
um they were targeting the pre-harmon
discovery that we want more base and uh
for that you know they deserve some
credit there's certainly designs gone
into it
so we see that we get to hear around 200
and then the curve just hugs our
preference in here
yes it's 102 db higher but remember what
i said this preference curve is very
approximate
do not go crazy thinking you need to
correct for this 2db
thing for all we know it you know a
different mounting or different version
of this headphone
or this preference curve could be wrong
by 2db
also keep in mind that there's no
standards for tonality music whoever
makes your music may have too much in
here or too little in here
so ultimately you know we have a compass
in here not a gps
we know which one the true north is
which is roughly this kind of shape
but not down to one or two db in here
but as we go past 1.23 kilohertz we see
that
from 1.2 all the way up to 3 kilohertz
we are deficient in this area we're
actually lower than our preference curve
uh the curve gra you know the way it
follows up is actually
similar to this but we do have
deficiency in here
and i'll talk about this when it comes
to equalization once we get to three or
four kilohertz
we see that it overshoots it has you
know probably some kind of resonance in
there they're stronger
than we want it to be so here we have
some different
some extra energy but the two channels
don't match so
watch out there's some you know we don't
necessarily want to take one or the
other and even average may be wrong but
so
level of uncertainty starting to
increase in here
as we go to the right we see now we have
the opposite problem again we have some
deficiency in here we have a hole
so we probably and i said emphasize
probably
that that we have some shortfall file
energy there
some treble here may be missing post
that
things get crazy if i show you other
headphones every one of them will go
nuts like this do not do not do not do
not
trust these measurements this is a lie
you get deep notches like this because
the sound from a headphone
hits the side of your head or your ear
changes phase and comes back and
combines with the oncoming direct sound
it actually cancels out
and because it cancels out because of
reflection in your ear you cannot
equalize you cannot fix this because
it's just factual life
that the physics of reflections in your
ear
is going to do this so ignore any
troughs or you know variability in here
some headphones will be really messy in
here
in general everything about the eight or
nine kilohertz is
unreliable anyway because the size there
is quite weak of how do we
come up with a calibration curve for
that in this case
so the way to interpret this area is
that i look at these peaks
and i sort of eyeball an envelope if i
were to just like completely get rid of
all the
ups and downs what would the line look
like and to me it looks like it would go
higher than our preference line it would
somewhat be like this
and indeed this preference line is a lie
because when harman measured their
speaker
no way a speaker in the room would have
a smooth response like this
it would also have reflections that
would go up and down there filtered
the heck out of that graph to give us a
simplistic line
okay so with respect to this thing
low frequency could be wrong
mid frequencies tend to be quite good so
between 200 hertz and
two or three kilohertz my jig basically
gives you correct data
within the standard deviation above that
boy better be very cautious you better
learn what you're doing
and how you interpret this stuff that's
why these reviews have a lot more text
in them
than my speaker reviews or electronic
reviews because there is a
process we have to go through to verify
that what we've done here
is correct okay now
the concept of getting used to flat not
being right is hard for some people to
understand they just like to see a flat
line meaning perfect and everything else
isn't perfect
but here i'm trying to teach you saying
the perfect is the blue
solid of the blue dash line and mentally
some people have trouble with that so
i'll show you different representation
but i really want to encourage you to
learn to like this presentation
and once you do you'll see that it works
better for you
but if we subtract these two curves from
each other what we get is the difference
or deviation or the error
so i call that the relative frequency
response or deviation
and it basically shows you what we
already know in base frequencies where
we have a deficit of 5 db then we go up
at 200 hertz
we're at 0 db announcer everything's
good everything's good
then here remember i said we had a
deficiency we get our first efficiency
then we get a little bit of too much
then we get deficiency
then we get craziness and you better
watch out what you're doing with this
craziness again
okay but i want to encourage you to do
this the i i think
as you learn will interpret this a lot
easier and
at all times you know the shape and how
the relative relationship
is and you'll get used to using this one
more
okay now um tonality
is the number one priority for both
headphones and speakers no question
about it
beyond that though it's very easy for me
to get a speaker or headphone to distort
i mean headphone
speakers turn it up and the bass usually
at some point the speaker blows his
brains out that
doesn't want to reproduce and gets
heavily distorted the research out there
is
is basically non-existent one or two
attempts have been made to characterize
distortion with preference
and the results were not conclusive
my opinion the testing was done
incorrectly in that if you take two
headphones
with two different types of frequency
response and two types of
distortion frequency response dominates
so of course
if the other one has a higher distortion
or lower distortion doesn't help it much
but to the extent frequency response is
what you want
then the lower distortion winds and the
lower dispersion especially wins if
we're going to boost things up
when we boost things up we also boost
distortion and in base frequencies at
least does not
linearly scale so if you double the
amount of base you may get four times
the amount of distortion
so it's important to measure for
distortion but also measure it and
present it correctly
here we see a presentation that uh that
i use but let me show you the
presentation
other people use they usually show you a
response graph which is basically the
measurement
i done in 4db that i use and by the way
everybody uses different numbers so
i use 94 because that's what was used in
the research i believe and also what my
fixtures calibrated for so i know that's
the most accurate
measurement and then you see the total
harmonic distortion in red
and the first and second harmonic orders
in here and
some people go show you high order once
and they get 5 000 graphs in here
i find that memorizing this graph
knowing what looks good one looks bad is
very hard
i help it by drawing an arbitrary 40 db
line in here and i say anything
above that is no good where did i get 40
tp out of my hat so
it's just a reference to have it doesn't
matter what it looks like
with the first review but as i have
tested more and more and more
speakers using the exact same standard
we can see which one is worse which
one's better
but i really want to encourage you to uh
learn to
look at this one which is the relative
frequency response
and this is basically thd percentage
which is what we use in
electronics which is uh what is the
distortion
uh basically saying what is this a ratio
of just because this goes up doesn't
mean that distortion has gone up
because the amplitude that has also gone
up on this thing
so and i run this test at three levels
94 104 and 114 db spl
people hear these numbers and they say
well that's insane like
is it 114 db you know jet taking off and
you're going to go def and everything
well 114 is quite loud but they also
then go back so i never
said 94. i'm telling you i've listened
to this sweep at 94.
yeah it's a little loud but it's
definitely doable it's not like
what you think it is because our
sensitivity when we listen to music
is quite poor in low frequencies and
that's where a lot of the db is wasted
on
94 db is like 25 db above threshold of
hearing at 20 hertz
you're only 25 db higher than base lock
so
don't be scared of these numbers you
don't want to be testing a much lower
levels than these
so 94 db is the baseline one in in
blue then i've got 10 db higher and you
notice that the distortion hardly
changes in here in red
basically this headphones like yeah i
can produce 94 104 no problem when i
switched to 114 db so i'm skipping 10 db
at a time
all of a sudden it gets unhappy in here
and we see basically there's something
in the middle here is getting unhappy
normally headphones go nuts in bass
frequencies this headphone is like
cruising in base frequencies even at 114
db decibels which is very loud
it only has this one percent distortion
at 20 hertz it's incredibly good
let me search you to a another headphone
that is three times its price two times
its price
um this abyss diner v2 headphone
look at its thc percentage first focus
on the bass
they're like astronomical even at 94 db
it's already up to three percent but
more important at this area our ethereum
threshold is pretty high
for um distortion but look at where our
ears are most sensitive which is three
to five kilohertz
and look at the distortions they're off
the chart in a three thousand four
thousand dollar
book obviously woman she was uh uh
three thousand dollar headphone uh can't
produce it low distortion
sound i mean give me a break it's just
really really
really bad so and a lot of headphones
have these kind of sloping up
you know distortion and bass now this is
good for us because as i
explained we want to boost the bass so
if we take our 94 db and that 10 db to
it
we only get up to here so we still
extremely low distortion with this
high five magnet g6 um
i run this test called the group delay a
lot of people ask me to run
timing tests and give me phase
information i'll do a video
to show you that all of that is
misguided but there is something in
there in this group delay and i won't
explain what it means
but essentially ideal headphone would
have this sloping down
like this and then it goes flatline
forever whenever
something different usually means
there's some kind of acoustic event
happening
inside there so instead of one source of
sound or multiple sources of sound
one way you get multiple sources of
sound is with reflections right you
memorize the sound comes in his
ear and goes back and whenever that
happens in high frequencies you get this
sharp cancellation
and that is the telltale sign that you
do not want to equalize
that area of of the frequency response
because equalizations in front of the
headphone if you lower the level both
the direct sound and indirect sound
change by the same level so the
cancellation remains the same
you can always tell this in the
frequency response anyway that you
shouldn't touch this because it'll have
those sharp troughs in here but
i'll mark him in here now in here in the
middle we see
a bunch of disturbances it visually
looks horrible
but i don't want you to go by that just
know that something's
technically not correct if you were the
designer of this headphone you would
want to investigate what's happening in
here
whether resonance is or what is causing
that we don't know but we see the sign
of it over here look at the distortion
climbing in the same region
that it does here but again thankfully
at lower levels
it's just very much under control so the
only thing you want to get out of here
is that don't eq this sharp
corresponding you know at 10 kilos don't
go eq anything on 10 kilos or this one
wherever that is
and uh be careful some of these peaks
also
you don't want to go and try to equalize
but otherwise this part of the graph
looks pretty good
efficiency of speakers is quite
important
if you just have a phone and you want to
drive a
headphone with it you want to have a
very efficient headphone
you don't want to use one that needs
gobs of power
and so what i do is i i take my 94 db
measurement and then i measure
electrically what voltage do i need
coming out of a headphone amp to
generate 94 db
which again remember 94 db is not ear
piercing
is is good competent maybe a little loud
but
you know it's a good volume you should
be able to produce that
and here you see this nadhb 650
it only requires 55 millivolts but this
one i just measured he6 requires 1.2
volts
so 1.3 volts so by far is the least
efficient headphone i've
measured and it has that reputation that
it needs extremely powerful amplifiers
in the old days that was not available
and people would go get home power amps
for speakers and then try to drive this
with it and the problem with those
amplifiers that they may have too much
noise in them today i had no trouble
driving uh
this hd6 with either my topping a90 or
my rme adi2
dac uh both of them drove it to
loud enough where i i was not
comfortable
on this deck so the other thing is that
impedance i when i test headphone
amplifiers i test them with 32 ohm load
and
300 ohm load because with a 300 ohm load
how much
voltage an amplifier produces determines
how much power you get but when you go
the other extreme at 32 ohm
um current determines the amount of
power you get
so i test both extremes so when i'm
testing headphones i want to give you an
idea of which set of measurements you
want to go look at
this headphones 50 ohms sometimes i test
that 50 ohm with my headphone amps but
when i don't you want to more or less
pay attention to the 32 ohm measurements
because it's going to be
current sensitive the other thing is
that the impedance
is 100 flat what that means is that if
you have a high impedance
headphone amplifier like a tube one um
and if this is variable
it will act it can change the frequency
response of the uh
uh headphone amp can change the
frequency response of the
headphone by a little bit um but when
it's flat
it it basically makes it less loud and
you get more losses in the headphone amp
so it's not a problem
so this headphone doesn't care if you
use a two-pad fan to draw a
tube amp to drive it but i can tell you
so inefficient that the tube amp would
crumble and die on the load that it
needs the amount of current this thing
needs
two bumps tend to be okay for high
impedance
headphones but for low impedance they're
just deadly
so we get to listening tests a lot of
people
say that i don't listen i just look at
the graphs i don't know what the heck
where they get that information because
if you look at my reviews i'd say 70 80
of them have listening tests when it
comes to both speakers
and headphones i absolutely listen i
listen and i'll do a longer video on
this but i listen to say hey
are the measurements accurate or not
and i also listen to see generally do i
enjoy this or not
when i put these on i said
wow sounds good and by the way i
listened to them before i did all these
measurements
i was testing headphone amp and i put it
on and i listened i remember
you know my for some reason i thought it
wouldn't sound good you know put it on i
was like whoa
this sounds good and uh i came over here
this time i did have the measurements
and i put it on i was like this sounds
good
but uh ever slightly bright you know
it was like a little little pitchy uh i
mean you could tolerate it but
but i'm sensitive i don't want too much
eyes in there because i think
it just gets to me after a while so i
went in there and i put in
um four filters i always try to minimize
number filters i put in there
and i always go after the big fish all
of the filters that i design
are done by eye what does that mean i go
look at this curve
and i say okay that says we're down 3d
where
in this peak is 3 db higher than it
should be
and what's the shape okay it looks like
it goes from 2k
to 7k let me go ahead and
create a filter that does more or less
what that does
you could mechanically generate a much
more accurate one
but remember the measurements and the
target curve are not very accurate
so getting this number like this one
instead of being
5 db being 5.5 db and this being 1.65 db
is fantasy there's such accuracy in the
measurement data
just because you can go compute accurate
data
doesn't mean that you land with the
better measurements so anyway
i put these filters in one at a time
and then i experiment or focus only in
that energy like when i put this
bass boost in here for sub bass i turn
it on
and first listen to my average tracks to
make sure nothing's under boomy
then i go play the ones with the deep
sub bass frequencies 20 30 40 hertz in
there
and i'd listen to them did they get
distorted
dude are they still lost and i can't
hear them and i
and i adjust this now to taste you may
want to go higher than this but you can
see i only pick like uh
uh 60 hairs to start only five dbs i
dialed in
i forget what our shortfall was but i
just put five in there it worked
i was done that's the other thing i
don't kill myself whether it's my own
system
or i'm reviewing somebody else's product
i get close enough
i'm done i'm not spending a lifetime
tuning something like this i want to
enjoy music go on about my life
so then we have the shortfall in here
i'll put that in there turn it on turn
it off turn it on turn it off
go through the exact same reference
tracks that i listen to
every time is the effect positive is it
pleasant is it not pleasant is it not
pleasant
um by the way sometimes close my eyes
and i randomize the stuff then i listen
with my eyes closed so i can't even tell
which one i'm testing whether it's
equalized or not if the outcome is not
always positive
then i don't go with that eq and
and so on so you can see this final one
in here for example was for the
brightness
i put one in there it just brings all
the levels down maybe it needed to be
like this rather than flat
but hey this one worked and then i do a
full
on off testing where in my room player
where i put this eq
i can just turn everything on and off
and
able to uh tell whether the effect is
overall positive for all the filters
put in there in this case i had my son
with me
and uh he listened and i had him test it
and
he also agreed that with eq all this
sounded better than
than not so um
this is a key part of headphone reviews
you cannot just look at my uh
measurements if you're doing just that
you're making a mistake
because again these are approximate
measurements and an approximate target
how do we verify how much of this graph
is real
depends highly on listening tests and
the nice thing is that many of you have
access to equalization
we have a client member that converts my
parameters to
promise for a bunch of other equalizers
go ahead and dial them in a lot of
people have the same headphones
and i say eight or nine out of ten times
people come back and say yeah put in
your
cube wow it sounded better or modular
sound or better
occasionally somebody says well you know
well maybe it was a little too much bass
so i pulled it down
so so far the track record across 30 40
headphones i've tested
has been quite good that this two
[Music]
system of measuring and then correcting
based on measurements and then
optimization of the correction using
ears
is working okay you have to get
upset this 10 times you have to get used
to uncertainty in here
nothing about these headphone reviews or
absolute
but i want them to be far more reliable
than some subjective guy who just puts
these headphones on and
raves about all kinds of fancy things
that you don't have no idea if it's
right or not or something it just gives
you measurements it says go run with it
and here's some eq that mechanically
generated i'm like
great you know what what does that mean
so you're getting a hybrid in here of
listening tests and measurements no
they're not double blind listening tests
and what have you
but again practically we go you know
share this data and see where they go
now there's one effect in here that is
very important with headphones that i
don't usually put this allowance for
speakers as much at least
is this what i call spatial quality um
and it's hard to i can tell you a little
bit about how to quantify it but
some headphones you put them on and the
sound is just very close to your head
and the instruments are sort of you know
together
a few of them and this is one of them
and sennheiser
hd 800s is the other one do this magical
thing where
every instrument appears to be slightly
separated than the other one
it's a very cool effect i don't know if
it's true fidelity probably isn't
you never hear that with speaker and
live music your head isn't inside the
orchestra and orchestra being miniature
around your head but you hear this very
pleasing
layering of this stuff and no it's never
a white sound stage it never
goes in front of me i don't know where
these people imagining
all this in headphone reviews i've
tested likes of 40 headphones and
i've yet to hear what they're described
what is the sound stage wide or very
deep
they're always around my head and a
little bit to the back
but this layering is very special i had
not heard another
headphone come close to uh sennheiser
800s and 800s has large cups and it's
got them angled
so i think that creates some kind of
timing cues some special
characteristics that's pleasing
i can usually improve this aspect in
just about every headphone
how do i improve it i look for shortfall
in this region
i guarantee you if you have a short file
between
one and three five killers three to four
killers
if i boost that the sound opens up sound
stage opens up
because in that region is where you have
a lot of channel separation
in music and when you have a recessed
area in that region
soundstage collapses on its own because
you have less differential information
for each year
that's at least contributes to it i have
done tons of eq in this region
and i can guarantee you that result for
that reason it's painful when i have to
bring it down
because i know i can get the tonality
right but when i do that i lose some
sound stage
i hate those headphones because now you
have a trade-off and which one's right
it's up to your preference most of the
time though it's like this where i'm
able to actually improve what's
uh characteristics of a headphone i can
actually hype it up
and get the tonality to be more correct
at the same time so it's a nice win-win
situation
sorry guys my nose has been itching off
the whole video i keep scratching it
anyway on this thing so please please
pay attention to uh listening test
for headphones even for speakers and
i'll cover that in another video
it's important to listen and and see
what i do with equalization there's a
reason i
do all this stuff i i gotta tell you i
was very worried about having to
spend the time to listen to these
products both headphones and speakers
and i thought well it wouldn't be great
to just put out measurements i wish i
could get away with just putting out
measurements
uh but i just can't you've got to have
a mix of the two to build the story
that's credible the sticks
specifically i don't want to tell you
here's the most perfect measuring
thing and then go listen to it myself
and say hey this doesn't sound good
how would i ever be able to explain that
to you if i run into the street and you
ask me
like but how does it sound oh so i'm
terrible like well
what you say was a great headphone well
because the you know the graph was close
to the
measurement it's just a science the
science here is incredibly powerful
incredibly useful
but you have to be able to develop an
eye for approximation
trends envelopes and overall uh
assessment of of a product not just you
know
specifics of it so anyway this is a good
headphone
fortune is discontinued and also
secondarily was thirteen hundred dollars
when new
so i'll be you know i've tested other
headphones that are great so
other choices and i'll be testing more
in hi-fi man
online also okay sorry this video is
long hopefully you learned something out
of it as far as
how to read these frequency response
measurements and and my workflow
uh in there so that in the future i
don't have to emphasize it as much
okay see you in a future video bye-bye